welcome back tonight the bite
administration cave into the fears of
the left on the nation migrant asylum
crisis president biden chose to keep
15 000 person cap on refugees
entering the u.s but that wasn't good
enough for aoc who tweeted
quote utterly unacceptable holding the
xenophobic and racist policies of the
trump administration
but after that the administration
changed courts releasing a statement
tonight
reading we expect the president to set a
final increased refugee cap
for the remainder of the fiscal year by
may 15th
here now kaylee mackinney former white
house press press secretary
and a fox news analyst kaylee um
is this how we're going to run the
country now every time
aoc decides to throw a tamper a temper
tantrum
and go on twitter then we're just going
to cave our foreign policy to that right
lawrence that's exactly what we're
seeing here with this this is a
government
run by progressives i i said in the
campaign look if biden prevails
he is an empty vessel who will be
totally driven by the radical left
progressive wing of the party and that's
exactly what we're seeing and also worth
mentioning here is just the
totally muddled message from the white
house literally last week jin saki tells
us that he's going to raise the cap
uh then this week today he comes out and
says the low cap remains justified
by humanitarian concerns then we get an
aoc tweet
and voila here we are uh raising the cap
once more it's amazing it's not a way to
govern also a lesson
and very poor messaging yeah so we've
got the aoc
and the radical progressive but i think
it goes to the
root cause of this that they keep
changing the policy when it comes to
refugees and they want to have legal
immigration reform done but they don't
want to get control of the border first
aren't they making the same mistake over
and over again
yes i think it's a great point you know
of course we remember
from the white house podium when we were
told all children are going to be
accepted
into the interior of the country and
there we go all of a sudden you have an
influx of unaccompanied minors to the
border
now what message does this send all
children are welcome we will raise our
our asylum our refugee cap uh and we
will welcome that as well it's sending a
message said
setting a magnet they call it a pull
factor to bring these illegal immigrants
in
um in this case they would be legal
immigrants but just raising this number
is another way that they're putting fuel
on the fire and one more point
just uh then this two question press
conference what a joke his second press
conference the two question press
conference
uh not a single reporter thought to ask
about this refugee cap situation
i gotta get your comment on on this uh
there was a lot of talk about
bounties put on u.s social soldiers
you addressed this back in the day at
the white house i want to play this and
get your reaction on it
the front page of the new york times is
not the venue for discussing classified
information
this is a piece of intelligence
information that had no consensus
has not been verified still to this day
has not been verified
now they they changed course today they
said some of the intelligence was wrong
i'm just going to call it a flat-out lie
it was a flat out lie
by the new york times uh by cnn by msnbc
by the washington post who
had the audacity to call trump a liar
over it when in fact they were the ones
corroborating a report and lying and for
a month
more than that even i fielded questions
about this from the podium having to
talk about raw intelligence
from the white house podium see it on
the cover of the new york times it is an
absolute travesty
and still they're not coming out and
apologizing they owe president trump and
the entire administration at least that
yeah i won't hold my breath for apology
because they never do they just continue
to lie and we continue to allow them to
get away with it it's sad thank you
kaylee thanks lawrence